Before we get started, I want to be clear about
what we're not going to teach you in this course. We're
not going to be teaching mobile frameworks like bootstrap, or
native app wrappers like PhoneGap. These are great tools, but we
want to teach the fundamentals that you as a mobile
web developer need to know first. Many of our coding examples
are centered around a single conference application, which we put in
a GitHub repository. Not every concept fits well in that app,
so we'll be using other examples too. We're going to begin
with a lesson on mobile development tools, showing you how to hook
up the DevTools to your mobile browser. If you already know how
to do this, feel free to skip this section. Let's get started.